kyle goon joins us uh southern
california news group covering the
lakers and an nba writer
uh kyle thanks for joining us is uh
everything good with the lakers now
after polishing off the blazers uh
that's that's a complicated question dan
um i i would say
the the tone of saturday um
was a lot was a a lot happier and
and healthier than perhaps it wasn't
earlier in the week obviously wednesday
night
there was a thought that perhaps the
lakers would would be one of the
foundational teams in
actually sitting out the rest of the
games of the season um but
you know on saturday night they closed
at the blazers it took them a couple
extra days
but they took care of business now they
have a couple days off families are
supposed to
some families are supposed to arrive
today and that's a really big moment
that a lot of players on a veteran team
have been looking forward to
so i would say they're they're doing a
lot better um but obviously
there's been a lot of shaking up in the
last week well i'm looking at the latest
column from you and granted you don't
write the headline but it says after a
trying week and a lakers series win
lebron james pulls back from the brink
yeah well i mean you you have to
really understand that um you know
lebron
tried to tell us the other day that he
was not upset um i think that he was i
think he that he was frustrated
um on wednesday night when he realized
that
um you know milwaukee had staged
a protest that they kind of thought was
going to be one game one
forfeit a very sort of organic moment
not really
communicating with the rest of the
league but obviously
you know there's a lot of tension among
you know athletes
uh for sure who are some of the most
prominent
and and resourceful people of color in
the whole country
and it struck a nerve i think that the
bucks did not realize that it would
and then once players were meeting later
that night
when lebron who definitely understands
the power and ramifications of a move
like that
got got to that meeting he realized
there was nothing
that that milwaukee was prepared to ask
for to resume
play they just thought hey we're gonna
we're gonna go out for game six and try
to win our series then
so i think that was the frustration i
don't know how close
he was um to to actually walking out i
don't think he had his bags packed or
anything but i think
there was a lot of thought given to the
fact that
you know if if we aren't asking for
something what are we doing here
we have more concerns about the lakers
on the floor off the floor
uh me i think off for sure um and
another thing lebron said
that night and and partly in jess but
partly not is that
he's giving him thought to leaving the
bubble every day
um and you know it's such a weird
situation
here dan because um you know i
understand what he means
i mean there's just not another
there's just not a lot of outlets
there's not a lot of changing routine
you have isolation from the people you
love and i think
um there's something really profound
about
um just the when something happens in
the outside world like the jacob blake
shooting and obviously a lot of players
care
it just there it really makes the
feeling of helplessness
and frustration more pronounced and i
honestly think
that the bubble has a lot to do with the
buck's decision to try and forfeit that
game
got a long way to go though the bucks do
and the lakers these are
you know the two favorites here yeah
yeah and and we've already done
uh you know 50 some days and we got 40
some days to go i'm i'm also here the
entire way
um so it's definitely it it can feel
like a long
um look up at the to the top of the
mountain i think
um so i think for some guys i mean
obviously george hill said
even before that we shouldn't even come
to this place
um i'm being polite language for your
listeners um but
it guys were feeling it um and i think
that's
um inextricable from what actually
happened that guys were feeling
frustrated guys were feeling like
you know we're putting these messages
out there we have these messages on the
back of our jerseys
um we have the messages on the court and
what
is it really making a difference is it
really being heard
um is there more we could do if we were
outside
and um you know i think that's something
that you really
feel here as long as we've been here
when you're in
isolation watching the clippers against
the mavs
i uh you know everybody was in on
portland upsetting the lakers and i said
you know dallas has a better chance of
upsetting the clippers i i
and if the clippers if if it had been
reversed and the
the lakers played the mavs then
everybody would have said all the mavs
can upset the lakers because everybody
you get clicks when you talk about the
lakers nobody was thinking hey let me
write about the clippers maybe getting
upset
i thought that they were perilously
close to being down three games to one
and i mean eventually we see the real
kawhi leonard stepping up
i just don't know if
who is going to be the guy you count on
to step up with kawhi because
as great as he is one guy's not winning
this title
with that team so yeah have you like
you look at the clippers and and the
lakers who would be your favorite
between those two playing for a
championship
that is a really good question and you
know this entire playoffs has been
i mean i think the mental edge is such
an x factor because i think the thing
happening with the lakers
um in the in the blazer series is one
thing that really need to happen for
them is anthony davis needed to believe
you know what like i don't really have a
match-up on this team and i think that's
going to be a constant battle
for the lakers in the same way obviously
paul george between the two
uh quote-unquote co-stars is is having a
rougher time
and has admitted to having a rougher
time and and i don't want to diminish
from that
um uh because it is very relatable to be
honest when you
when he said those things it's very
relatable as somebody who's been living
here
for about the same amount of time but
you felt the same things kind of
i mean i mean not checking out because
we
remain busy but just a desire to like
just change something about your
circumstances same room
same small area you go around when i run
i run in a circle around the coronado
springs resort
um so i think there's this sort of the
days can kind of blend together
and i mean guys have said this um so
it's just this
x factor that um you know it's really
hard to anticipate
and i think paul george's struggle with
that i think one reason kawhi
has not he told us last night when he
had that injury
with san antonio and he was rehabbing by
himself he's like all right like
all i did was kind of gym go home gym go
home
um and and he did that for what a year
and
he sort of has had that reclusive
experience away from
some others and and knows how to go
through it so i think that's why you've
seen he's been remarkably consistent
and he really is i mean if you if you
watched that series as great as in
spellbinding as luca was
kawhi was unguardable and he was hitting
shots that
you know you're sort of like well this
isn't really a great shot but for kawhi
he'll just hit he'll kill you in the mid
range because you'll just let him sit
and
it'll just pick you apart so i think
that's a great base
and if paul george can kind of figure
out some consistency
um and maybe that'll get easier as we're
sort of rolling downhill here
um i i would pick the clippers and and
like
over the lakers right now and pick em
but like
like i said and like you said it's
really hard to know mentally where
some of the guys are going to be at yeah
and i think that's really interesting i
appreciate you sharing your
personal feelings on that because it's
kind of like you know you're in the
you're in a bubble too you know we talk
about these athletes but you're in a
bubble too so you can certainly
understand that before i let you go
jamal murray averaged 18 points a game i
think this year
he's putting up 50 every night what has
changed with jamal murray in the bubble
you know it that is an interesting
question too because i think
for certain guys they're just shooting
lights out and i also look at
his counterpart in that series donovan
mitchell uh who i covered for a year
uh and i um i really enjoy watching play
but
he put up 250 pieces too it's kind of
unbelievable what's happening in that
series
um and and uh really i mean
pleased that it gets to go to seven
games but i think there are guys here
who
you know they really just do dive in on
that investment to basketball i mean
jamal murray has
been capable of of doing those kinds of
games just
not usually back to back to back yeah um
but i think
um there is something about this and and
guy where guys can seize on the emotion
of the moment can seize on the
hey we don't want to go home yet even
though maybe you do want to go home
in some respects but um it's been really
cool to watch i mean
dame dame before them in the seating
games all the way to make a run
and there's been some guys who really
have found a way to thrive in this
environment and
add it sort of to the it's us against
the adversity of the world mindset that
you were talking about with the big john
before the break so um it's been really
interesting and fun
and and sometimes really rewarding to
watch good luck there kyle
and we appreciate you joining us thank
you for having me dan
that's kyle goon he covers uh the lakers
for uh southern california
news group nba writer